Hi. My name is Magnus. I work for the
Google Drive team.
We're going to look at the Google Drive
integration for the ASUS PadFone device
which allows you to search in Google
Drive and it also incorporates the Realtime API.
Let's have a look.
In my opinion, the Google Drive API provides the most basic function of all: Search.
And the most basic function, Search, is what Google does best.
At a time when more and more data is in the cloud,
I still think that Search is the easiest
and most intuitive function to use.
It also offers the ability to upload whole folders.
This may seem like something basic,
but not every cloud service has this function.
Google Drive also provides a Realtime API
that makes it easy for our design team
to facilitate collaboration,
allowing many individuals to edit a single document simultaneously.
For me, Google Drive is more like a cloud integration service system
than an ordinary cloud storage service.
Before I give you the reasons why we choose
Google Drive to co-operate with,
let me share with you our criteria for choosing
components and partners from a product
manager point of view.
There are three criteria, number one is quality.
For every component that goes
into the device,
it should be of high and premium quality
no matter if it's the CPU,
the chipset, the software, the firmware
or the services. These should all be
of high quality. So we choose Google
Drive
for its most important trait: quality.
The second part is the ease of use.
It is very important
for us to think and to act like a user.
The integration of Gmail,
calendar, Picasa and all
other Google services really gives the user
true benefit and it is very user
friendly. So we choose
Google Drive for the second reason,
user-friendliness. Now comes the third part.
When we make any device, we want to have
innovation. In ASUS we always are thinking about
what other, better way there is to finish
the daily tasks of ordinary people,
how a device can help people.
So, PadFone together with Google Drive
means you can have a very easy way
of finishing almost 99% of
what you do on the web or on the go.